first of all miss Olivia hello how are
you doing how are you surviving this
crazy crazy time very interesting but
definitely surviving yeah I feel like it
comes in waves you know there's good
days there's the bad days some days are
harder than others obviously you I mean
we're on tour leading up into this whole
thing now that you are home and spending
probably more time at home than you're
used to like what have you been doing to
kind of past the time well at first I
was like trying a little bit I think I
was trying a little harder to stay
productive mm-hmm
I feel like in the past few days I've
been kind of stuck in a little like I
haven't been wanting to get up and do
the things I have to do crazy and even
before this I was on tour so I like
didn't meet my friend so I literally
haven't seen my friends in like two
months so I just never liked going
literally insane at this point I've been
watching a lot of Netflix the past
couple days just trying to like calm
myself down like trying to put off what
I have to do I think today I'm gonna try
to do stuff so what have you been
inspired at all during this time or
isolating not know I really wish I've
been trying like you know I texted all
my exes trying to get some inspiration I
just don't like I don't think that it's
possible for me to feel any emotions
right now because of how like crazy this
is like my mind just goes to like the
weirdest places all like I just can't
yeah how did that go you texted your
exes during quarantine um you know it
was interesting I realized that they're
all still pieces of garbage you're like
it was validation that you made the
right choice back back in the day okay
you're I was gonna say it worked out
though right you're better off
well let's talk about the fact that yeah
you were on tour it did you even had
dates scheduled through late March of
course those were all postponed because
of Kovan 19 I can't even imagine as an
artist going through this like
especially we're like actively touring
and and putting on shows were you super
bummed I was so bummed like that's this
tour is like one of the
things I'm most proud of like yeah I've
ever done and also like I paid for it
pretty much all myself it's like I'm not
like you know the biggest artist in the
world so it just it's like my like child
like I've put everything into this
torrent a huge investment yeah for real
and but it's okay because hopefully you
know it'll it'll pick up whether it's
soon or later I'm still gonna probably
use the same like visuals and continue
my tour that I created so I'm not I'm
trying not to be too bummed about it so
it's like you can't control it doesn't
do my next question like whether or not
you would kind of like change it up at
all but there's a whole other half of
the country I'm sure that's what wants
to see the show that you put together I
mean I'm sure I'm gonna have to change a
few things like I'll probably play a few
more songs or whatever change a few
things here and there but overall I
think it'll probably be really slow
can I be honest with you I'm bummed I
didn't get to see you at Coachella I was
I know and I can't even go to the
rescheduled October date so like
Coachella just a wash with me this might
happen
I might have it even later I might have
it next year like we don't we don't know
anything I I don't know how it works
with scheduling stuff but I get there
worked and you had them like just you
coach our maybe next year would you be
up for it I would play Coachella is like
that's I mean I think it's a lot of
artistry but it's particularly liked by
my actual favorite festival and I know
feel like it's it's so like overrated
like people think it's overrated but
it's in my mind like it's it's over
reason like it is it is what it it lives
up to the hype I love patella I do want
to talk about your music because fans
are so obsessed with Jocelyn
I know that you said it was inspired by
like a real person a real situation but
loosely right I mean the song is 100%
about like a person but I feel like I
have to kind of just make it a little
bit more you know crazy yes I'd say in
the song it's not about someone that I
actually dated I always say like I refer
to like guys that I used to talk to us
like my exes like I said I text my ex
earlier like I didn't date any of those
boys like hi they're just our boys that
made me mentally well emotionally I'm
loved oh yeah yeah so it's it's
definitely about a real situation but
it's not the girl's name is Dawson what
I love about this track in particular
it's like yeah you're talking about the
other woman but the song is about the
dude like I hope it was worth it like
you're putting the responsibility on
them yeah yeah and I I'm it's kind of
upset me how many people I see saying
like eff Joss and like Jocelyn sucks
like this girl must really hate Jocelyn
like that's not the point of the song
like the point of the song like I
thought that was a pretty name and it
sounds so good with like the rhymes the
way I say like I feel like it it has
like the hits hard it has like the anger
and when I say it yeah but it's the song
that's completely directed at the guy
like all at him so I I just hope that
people can see that and understand that
I would never come after like a girl for
like what I'm like I'm she was just
trying to like have some fun
well let me ask you this do you know
Jocelyn's in your life have you ever
maybe been a Jocelyn um I mean I think
there's been there's definitely actually
recently there's been situations where
guys have like flirted with me or like
acted like whatever but I've never like
I always figure out like oh they have a
girlfriend or Oh like they're talking
someone and then I'm like I cut it off
it's like god it's not cute but I think
a lot of people can be that unknowingly
or like or it might feel like I know
there's definitely situations where like
a guy will break up with a girl or girl
bring up the guy whatever and then
they'll they'll tell someone else like
oh yeah we're completely over but and
they're like still seeing the person
kind of
there or like it's not fully over and
there's just complicated yeah and so
sometimes it's hard to even know if
you're that person but if I ever like
know that or figure that out I know you
said you had texted your exes in
quarantine are you talking to anyone new
in quarantine like I don't know how that
would work but I tried but it's just so
hard like you can't hang out with them
and then how do you like I'm not gonna
FaceTime someone every day and then what
if I like meet them in real life they
are horrible like I'm also I'm so picky
like I'll flirt with whoever but when it
comes like actually like being someone
I've only really like like written songs
like been inspired by like three guys in
my life and that it just takes such a
specific type of person and such a like
I don't even know how to explain it it's
like one in a million that you find that
so I know I'm not like gonna find that
while I'm in quarantine so why even
bother why and I can just I could just
sit here and like watch Netflix and also
it's hard to tell someone's actual
motives during this time because yes
they're available now like maybe a chat
with you because they're at home but
it's like will that actually do they
genuinely want to make a connection like
outside of this whole experience you
know it's hard to tell her and that
would be me I'm the person that would I
think yeah it's before your neck song
actually that's a really good topic I
loved it wrapping things up here
obviously this I feel like just because
of the uncertainty anxiety is at an
all-time level and I know obviously even
really open about your own depression
and mental health and I want to know if
you have a message to share people who
are kind of struggling emotionally and
mentally in quarantine what do you have
for them um I would say don't be too
hard on yourself and don't feel like
there's something that you specifically
need to be doing right now kind of like
what we talked about earlier you just
everyone's going through this and it's
really hard and the world hasn't seen
something like this in a very long time
so it's it's normal to feel messed up by
it and it's everyone is gonna feel that
some way or another during all this so
just don't get too hard on yourself and
know that it
we'll pass that this whole thing will
pass eventually even if it takes a while
gonna it's gonna go I'm things will go
back to normal so you just have to like
kind of push through
[Music]